we'll get back to the partygate uh story
uh in just uh a moment uh instead let's
uh get to martin brunt who is uh uh
outside uh the old bailey for us uh with
the sentencing uh of the man who
murdered sir david
given as widely anticipated a whole life
sentence for the murder of sir david
amos
in the last minute or so
the judge has
delivered that sentence i don't think
anybody will be surprised at it
the judge mr justice sweeney said there
were no mitigating circumstances
no mitigating factors that would steer
away from a whole life sentence which
effectively means that ali harbi ali who
is 26
today will spend the rest of his life in
jail without
the possibility of parole um the judge
uh said that this was a murder that
struck
at the heart of democracy he reviewed
much of the evidence um against ali
harvey ali remember
that he had admitted the killing
he said he'd done it as an act of
revenge uh he'd targeted sir david amos
because of his what he described as his
voting record particularly his support
for the uk's bombing of isis positions
in syria
the judge said that ali had
tried to get out to syria to support
isis
but had been frustrated so chose a
domestic
terror target and in fact we heard
impact statements from other people who
were originally chosen as targets for
ali harbi ali
including michael gove cabinet minister
uh also michael freer
the mp
and notably june
cushions who was sir david's
parliamentary aide who was there at the
surgery in leon
c in essex at the time of the murder she
said in her statement she still felt
great guilt that she was the one who had
chosen that venue where sir david was
murdered she'd chosen that venue for his
constituency surgery into which ali
harvey had tricked his way before
stabbing sir david
21 times
she also talked about
her other guilt her frustration and not
being able to help her boss at the time
so a whole life
order
life forever in prison
for ali harvey alley we spoke earlier to
nick price who is the head of counter
terror
for the crown prosecution service
and he said that this murder of sir
david amos was an attack
not just on an mp
but on society as a whole this is more
of what he had to say
the brutal murder of sir david ames
was a disgusting and cowardly act
visited on a man who was simply there
serving his community
as he had diligently done
for so many years
this was not just an attack
on sir david ames awful as that was
this was an attack on all of us
it was an attack on our society
and it was an attack on our democracy
the crown prosecution service
counterterrorism division
has worked closely with the metropolitan
police
to ensure that we could present all of
the evidence
to the court
to ensure
that the court could see
all of the evidence
leading to this conviction
i hope that today's sentence
demonstrates that there is no place in
our society
for acts
ideologically motivated
acts of terror
and that those
planning
to
uh
behave in that manner
will be
convicted
and will be visited with very long
prison sentences
obviously today our thoughts are with uh
sir david's family and his friends
their pain and suffering
does not end with the conclusion of the
criminal proceedings
so in fact two whole life sentences for
ali habi ali remember that he was
convicted of murder and
the preparation of acts of terror so a
whole life sentence
on both of those um and in respect of
that second
uh that second conviction
this was all about his
stalking uh his wrecking of the homes of
victims that he had chosen before sir
david amos
the judge made the point that he had
anticipated
attacking somebody at the house of
commons but found the security there
much too tight with lots of armed police
officers so he chose
uh the homes and constituencies of a
number of mps and we did hear
impact statements
from some of those including
michael gove
the cabinet minister
he talked about very briefly in his
statements about the effect
of learning
that he had been a potential target at
least
the effect on his family
so mike
michael freyr mp another chosen
potential target of ali harbi ali
he too described the moment that
counter-terror please came to him
after the uh david amis murder and told
him that he too had been a potential
target he said that he's had to suspend
his
constituency surgeries until
better security
has been put in place he talked about
the anxiety still suffered
by his staff he talked about
how constituents who want to visit his
office have to show
enhanced uh identity
identification
there was also an impact statement
given to the judge
but not read out
from sir david amos's
widow julia and some of his children
remember he was the father of five
children a son and four daughters well
there were impact statements from them
talking
uh about the effects that the loss of
their father
has had
on them but they made it clear said the
prosecutor that they wanted those
statements
to remain confidential
the judge said simply that he
acknowledged that he would keep them
confidential of course but he had led
um the impact that
david's
murder had had on his family
the judge went on to say
moments before he handed down those
sentences
that sir david amos was a man of
greatest substance who'd done nothing to
justify
the attack on him and he went on to say
that his loss
is one of national significance
um
i'm not aware that there was any
noticeable reaction
from ali harvey uh at that sentence uh
he may well have been expecting it
his lawyer probably told him that it was
likely he would face a whole life
sentence
so he joined a rogue gallery of
something like 60
people who are in currently in british
jails facing
whole life sentences
they include some notorious
murderers like levi bellfield like wayne
cousins
uh jailed here in similar circumstances
with a whole life sentence
last year
and also of course thomas mayer
who was the killer the murderer of the
mp joe cox
um
in in
2016. he of course was driven by a very
different
ideology a right-wing white supremacist
ideology but he too
was given a whole life sentence which is
just is what's been handed down
in the last few minutes
to ali harbi ali here for the
yes that's right i mean he qualifies